after months of bloody fighting
ukrainian soldiers at the besieged azov
style steel plant laid down their arms
and started being evacuated by russian
forces as prisoners apparently seeding
control of mariupol
soldiers being carried out to buses
could be seen in footage shared by local
authorities and russian media after
russia announced an agreement for the
wounded to leave
the site was the final holdout of
ukrainian soldiers who had resisted
russia's occupation of the strategic
port city even after moscow declared
control over mariupol in late april
here's how as of style where hundreds of
civilians had also taken refuge for
weeks became one of the most dramatic
battles in the war and captured the
world's attention
as the russian army turned marupo into
rubble over the course of three months
it failed to quickly seize the azov
style plant
in a televised address last month putin
ordered his troops to temporarily pause
the attacks and secure the area
the site is a cold war-era labyrinth of
warehouses tunnels and rail tracks
spanning a territory of four square
miles
alongside the as of style fighters
hundreds of civilians got trapped
throughout the siege the ukrainian
soldiers posted videos of the dire
situation online showing children and
women as well as the conditions they
lived in and calling for help
[Music]
in early may the fighters said they were
let down by politicians and criticized
kiev for abandoning them
um
the ukrainian president had called on
russia to release or exchange those
remaining at as of style
these pleas and the worsening
humanitarian situation there got the
world's attention
in late april the un's secretary general
met with the russian president and asked
to set up civilian evacuations from as
of style following the visit hundreds of
people were escorted out via a united
nations brokered humanitarian corridor
but the fighters stayed on despite
dwindling prospects of a victory
the wives girlfriends and mothers of the
azov style forces lobbied for their
rescue
some embarked on an international tour
including a visit to the pope
on monday ukraine said about 260
fighters were taken to russian-held
areas and that they will be exchanged
for captured russian soldiers
while efforts continued to evacuate
remaining defenders
the kremlin said the soldiers would be
treated in accordance with international
standards
the end of the battle for mariupol is
likely to be viewed as a major victory
in moscow but kiev also called it
mission accomplished as a prolonged
resistance helped the ukrainian army to
organize its resources
video
[Music]